Speaker 1: And there's another pretty significant
and very interesting, by the way, lawsuit
that also was revealed last week.
This lawsuit came from Michael Cohen, Donald
Trump's former lawyer, who recently completed
his three year prison sentence.
And this one to me is absolutely fascinating
here.
And if you're not familiar with it, I know
David has actually interviewed, interviewed.
Excuse me, that was weird.
Michael Cohen, I think a couple of times and
I think he's going on Michael Cohen Show.
But anyway, if you're not familiar with Michael
Cohen's imprisonment, very weird situation,
right?
He's in prison for a year.
COVID hits and of course, trying to prevent
the spread of COVID in our prisons.
They say, OK, we can send Michael Cohen to
house arrest, right?
He's not a not a violent guy.
Clearly not a threat of repeat offenses here.
So we can send him home and he can finish
out his sentence there.
And they did that.
Then a couple of weeks later, they said, Oh,
you know what?
Send him back to jail, but you know, don't
just send him back to jail.
Put him in solitary confinement for a couple
of weeks.
During which time Michael Cohen says he experienced
severe health problems, including anxiety.
And then finally, after all of this happens,
a judge comes out since Michael Cohen back
home because as the judge said, Well, here
it is.
Prosecutors insisted probation officers had
been unaware of the forthcoming book when
they wrote a provision severely restricting
Cohen's public communications.
But a federal judge ordered him returned to
home confinement, saying Cohen's return to
Otis Phil had been quote retaliatory.
And that is exactly what Michael Cohen is
alleging in the lawsuit he has filed, which
was announced last week against Donald Trump,
alleging that because Michael Cohen, when
he was released from jail to home confinement,
the first time he had been speaking out, you
know, talking to the press, he'd been doing
interviews and he had a book coming out a
tell all book.
And he's alleging in this lawsuit that Trump
was angry about this, and therefore the administration
pulled some strings, sent him back to jail.
And even the judge who looked at this again
because these circumstances were beyond bizarre
said this was retaliatory.
So when again, much like the Dominion suit
against Fox, when the judge is already saying,
yeah, I mean, it really looks like X. Michael
Cohen says, you know what?
Then I'm going to sue for X, we're going to
do this.
We're going to find out exactly what happened.
And I support this lawsuit, I would like to
see this again.
Michael Cohen's paid his debt to society.
He was sentenced to three years served as
three years.
And then that weird little thing in the middle
that made no sense.
Because they said, no, you cannot talk to
the press, you can't talk to the media, you
can't do any of this.
That's that's bizarre.
It's even more bizarre to throw him back in
prison for it, put him in solitary confinement.
For 16 days.
Something is absolutely fishy here, and I'm
glad Cohen has filed this lawsuit because
not only does he deserve answers for this,
but the public does.
This could be a potential abuse of power obviously
coming from the Trump administration.
So this lawsuit would serve not just to help
Michael Cohen.
But also to help the public itself, to find
out what the heck happened with these truly
beyond bizarre circumstances of his re imprisonment
during a time when the nation was trying to
get as many people out of prison as possible
to help slow the spread of COVID, we've still
got a lot more stories to cover.
I am Farron Cousins.
You can find me on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram
at Ferron Balanced.
You can also give me on YouTube at youtube.com
slash fair and balanced youtube.com.
Slash the ring of fire.
We'll be right back with more on the David
Pakman show.